foreign
[Music]
well your little Act of uncivil
Disobedience inspired me John I'm
branching up
spreading my wings
how goes the ground farewell tour
coming to an end
so it seems so it seems
42 regular wasn't it
Kevlar front to back the latest and
Ballistic Chic appropriate for all
formal occasions weddings funerals high
table duels
after all man has to look his best when
it's time to get married
or married
goes out to you Mr Wick
42 regular wasn't it yeah
And So It Begins
I challenge him to single combat if you
win you'll have your freedom
amen
because
get bloodied
the only way John Wick will ever have
freedom
and peace
[Music]
yeah not really
yourself
[Music]